what's going on guys it is 4 a.m in the
morning here
and i was just about to go to bed when
we got this massive news from some
official sources
about a potential third myhere academia
movie
now if you go on the official my hero
website for the movies
uh as of recording this video you'll see
a brand new poster
of deku in some kind of new suit and
it was really giving me like fire force
type vibes like the aesthetic of the
whole thing
it's totally new we've never seen any
design like this before
in the manga or anime and i gotta say
i'm really liking it
on top of that there were two additional
posters one of them was shoto in a new
suit and
the design around his collar was really
awesome and of course we had a third
poster of baka go because
obviously you can't not have baka go
when you combine the three posters and
put them side by side
then you can see the number three is
spelled out in in roman numerals
so uh this is basically a confirmation
that the third movie is happening
i mean if it's not the third movie then
this might be the biggest troll in the
history of this series
just to put the number three up there
like that um but no i'm confident right
now
that it is confirming movie number three
the tagline is
he will meet the three musketeers and
let me briefly explain why that's so
significant
i'm sure many of you know about the
three musketeers
and they were the ones who made the
saying of all for one and one for all
like they were the ones who made that
saying popular um in fact the only
reason i know about the three musketeers
is because of that phrase you know all
for one and one for all
the three musketeers for movie number
three will uh obviously be deku
bakugou and todoroki which means that uh
based on this tagline
someone is going to meet them and that
person will
most likely be a villain how can they
top heroes rising huh i mean
we had deku giving one fraud to back ago
so what is he going to do now give it to
bacca and todoroki no i highly doubt
that but um
yeah it's just funny to think about but
um anyway when we look at bakago's
outfit
we can see that he's still wearing his
winter costume which led me to theorize
of when this movie can take place the
endeavor agency arc took place in the
winter
and in the mango we only really saw the
beginning of their internship
and the end of their internship so
during the actual week itself
there was a ton of time they spent with
endeavour that we never got to see
so i guess if this movie wanted to be
vaguely canon
the then it can take place during the
endeavor agency arc
we know that at the endeavor agency he
has a super fancy training facilities
and
basically a hotel um so maybe these
these outfits
were supplied by endeavor as well and
maybe they're just using them for a
specific mission
uh maybe they'll go somewhere snowy that
kind of you know needs a change of
outfit
the possibilities are endless right now
because all we have to all we have to go
off
is literally just these posters um but
still
going back to baccago's suit it is
pretty cool um
the one thing i do like about it is his
you know the grenades on his forearms
um they're a lot slimmer than his usual
ones and they just they just feel more
modern
you know just by looking at them um i'd
maybe this is an unpopular opinion
i don't actually like bakago's big bulky
grenades like as an
outfit i don't like it um when he has
them off i i prefer that
so um these ones right here i would
rather he use these all the time
but he probably won't it's probably just
a just a movie accessory
just like the thing that deku got in the
first movie from melissa's shield i
forget what it was called
but you know the red thing that he had
on his arm see it's probably going to be
like that they're just going to use it
once
and never use it again last thing to
mention before i go to bed
is that you'll notice there are badges
on the shoulders of each student
and it seems to say wha
now we have no idea what that stands for
right now
i was thinking maybe well my initial
idea was a
world hero association but i'm pretty
sure there is no
world hero association but that was the
first thing that came to my head
um then i was thinking maybe winter hero
attire
but then i'm like why would you need to
have a badge for that so
i don't know let me know in your let me
know your thoughts down below what you
think the wha stands for
but i guess we will find out soon enough
soon enough
i'll make another video about this when
we have more information but right now i
just kind of wanted to let you guys know
the news
and i also kind of wanted to go to bed
as well so uh
peace out guys and i'll see you in the
next one